[Music]
what a nice crowd so good to see you
uh conan i've said this before i'll say
it again good to see you
i'm curious i mean you laugh when i say
that but i am serious that took a lot
out of you and i appreciate it andy yeah
all right
he's good he remembers my name yeah i
just wanted to make sure he was back
there listen
kevin i love it when you're on the show
because you're a wise man uh and you uh
you you follow the news very carefully
and i'm i'm curious you must be
following the elections give us your
take
well i don't really have a take conan uh
but i watch them
and i know they're on tonight the debate
yes based on yeah yeah and um
i don't really believe any of the
politicians i really don't yeah
i don't i don't because they're not
they're not you don't believe any of
them no no if you want the truth ask a
child
and then punish them because
you don't get ahead in this world by
being honest this is what we've learned
ask a child and then punish it that's
terrible but yeah but i think that um
have you have you made up your mind
about who you're gonna vote well you
know
i think it would be great if barack
obama in the next couple of weeks
without saying anything just very
gradually started growing a big old afro
you know
stuck a pic in the back maybe you know
anything
because he really needs to intimidate
romney i think in this next debate maybe
he should wear a hoodie
i think that's the way to go yeah i'm
sorry what were you asking me
oh if i'm uh if i've made up my mind you
made up your mind yeah what kind of
candidate do you generally like
i like someone who cares about our
planet you know i'm trying to go green
we're going uh we're actually going
paperless in our house you are yeah and
it's presenting a little bit of a
problem in the bathroom i gotta be
honest with you it's uh yeah they should
have an app for that you know like a a
crap app or something oh my god yeah
that's a terrible idea no
what do you think the issues are that
could sway this election
i didn't realize the questions would be
so tough out here
well you know everyone seems to be uh
concerned about women's uh choices you
know
the
you know the freedom to choose
um here's what i think about abortion
a lot of people if i may yeah go ahead
if you want to get serious here sure
okay
uh what worries me is a lot of people uh
you know when does life begin is the
question and a lot of people think life
begins at 40.
that's what worries me
i worry about
[Applause]
it is a tough question when does life
begin
when does life end is a lot easier to
come up with you know that's one no one
seems to be arguing about yeah here's my
question for you if i may sure um it's
your show go for it okay
um let's say you're giving cpr to
somebody like mouth to mouth yeah and
you can't bring them back
when does that become necrophilia
serious when does
uh yeah these are the issues i want to
know about talk about let's take a quick
break you're
you're too big a fool i need to take a
quick break we're going to have more
with kevin neal in just a second